ce
[Musique]
qui avait le berceau de 3 et a slave
ukraine biélorussie et la russie après
le xiiie siècle les histoires de
l'ukraine et de la russie se séparent à
la fin du xviiie siècle l'empiré russe
met la main sur toute l'ukraine
dire que l'ukraine et slaves et donc
russe revient détruire notre identité
dit l'historien igor ponot march look
son musée contient la plus grande
collection d'icônes ukrainienne mais
aussi des peintures de la période
soviétique qu'il apprécie beaucoup moins
nombreux
[Musique]
pendant 400 ans pour les ukrainiens que
le pays se soit appelé empire russe
fédération russe urss ces gens de l'est
ont toujours voulu détruire notre pays
notre religion notre langue tout la
langue ici à zaporijia on parle russe
c'est historique parce que la langue
ukrainienne
a été menacé par les arts et les
empereurs russe c'est comme ça dans tout
l'est et le sud de l'ukraine je me sens
être chrétienne je suis je suis
ukrainienne kiev est ce c'est ce fait
que je jeu par le russe c'est historique
ça vienne de l'union soviétique nous
tous on est nés en union soviétique
maintenant nos enfants il parle peu
craignant et par l'ukrainien parce que
dans aux écoles ils apprennent en
ukrainien déjà ça commence ça commence
ça a déjà commencé
de plus en plus l'ukraine sucré knees
ceux des rues syfy
ici on songe à faire disparaître les
reliques soviétique de la seconde guerre
mondiale comme cet avion le monde entier
est étonné par la mobilisation de
l'armée ukrainienne et de la société
civile dans un pays qui se méfie de son
gouvernement et des politiciens
corrompus on prend les choses en main
spontanément on n'hésite pas à évoquer
les cosaques ap org qui depuis leur
forteresse de sa porridge à terroriser
toute la région jusqu'à la fin du xviiie
siècle bientôt tu perds pas convenu
boric pas au cas où tu dois revenir
dans son roman tarass boulba dont on a
tiré plein de films nicolas gogol est
écrit qu'un paysan kozak était à cheval
et en armes en une semaine et que toute
une armée était prête au combat en deux
semaines
stop the huntsman est la guerre c'était
comme mettre le pied dans une
fourmilière tout le monde s'est mis à
aider l'armée et les réfugiés c'est beau
de faire partie de ce mouvement
l'histoire se fait la nation se bat
c'est dur mais c'est inspirant les
jeunes volontaires de zaporizhya qui se
sont mobilisés pense déjà à l'après
guerre quand il faudra éliminer la
corruption et mettre sur pied des
gouvernements et des institutions
solides
à la fin de la guerre nous allons
construire la nouvelle ukraine dit
constante à jean michel leprince pas du
canada sapowicz